Ever since Will Smith infamously slapped
and cursed out Chris Rock at the 94th annual
Academy Awards over a joke the comedian made
regarding Smith's wife, Jada Pinkett Smith,
and her alopecia diagnosis, events have
unfolded rapidly. On March 28th, 2022,
following news that the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences had opened a formal review of
his behavior, Smith issued a public apology via
his social media. He admitted that his actions
at the ceremony were, quote, "unacceptable
and inexcusable," and expressed regret over
his loss of emotional control. While this
is certainly a step in the right direction,
it's not the punctuation mark on
the situation it may appear to be.
The Academy's board of governors convened
an emergency meeting that Wednesday to begin
the review process and assess what's next
for Smith. Possible consequences may have
ranged from being barred attendance from
future events to expulsion from the Academy
altogether. Some in the public have called
for these and other similar punishments,
and many have even advocated for the revocation of
Smith's first ever Oscar for Best Actor – which he
was awarded minutes after assaulting Rock
— for his performance in "King Richard."
Although, Academy governor Whoopi
Goldberg has come forward to emphasize
that they have no intention of
considering this as an option.
As the Academy continues to deliberate,
Will Smith has repeatedly acknowledged the
widespread harm his actions caused and accepted
the potentially severe consequences of his
behavior, taking a bold step in the process.
In a statement obtained on April 1st, Will Smith
once again took responsibility for his attack
on Chris Rock, calling his actions, quote,
"shocking, painful, and inexcusable," but he
didn't stop there. Smith also took the drastic
step of resigning his Academy membership. As is,
this move leaves him unable to vote on future
Oscar ceremonies and participate in other Academy
events. It remains to be seen if he'll still be
allowed to present the award for Best Actress next
year, seeing as that's traditionally the previous
year's Best Actor winner's responsibility.
In his missive, Smith noted that he had
responded to the disciplinary hearing notice
issued by the Academy and said that, in
addition to his resignation, he would, quote,
"accept any further consequences the Board
deems appropriate." Smith's statement continued,
"The list of those I have hurt is
long and includes Chris, his family,
many of my dear friends and loved ones, all those
in attendance, and global audiences at home.
I betrayed the trust of the Academy. I deprived
other nominees and winners of their opportunity
to celebrate and be celebrated for their
extraordinary work. I am heartbroken."
He adds that he seeks to change in the wake
of this event and is willing to do what he
must to ensure that he changes his ways
for the better — echoing sentiments that
Jada Pinkett Smith shared in a social media
post that promoted healing going forward.
Shortly after news of Will Smith's resignation
reached the public, he received a direct
response to his motion. Academy president David
Rubin accepted Smith's tender of resignation,
but clarified in a statement that
he's not off the hook yet. Rubin said,
"We will continue to move forward
with our disciplinary proceedings
against Mr. Smith for violations of
the Academy's Standards of Conduct."
The Academy's Board will convene once again on
April 18th to determine further consequences for
Smith, though one has to wonder how his departure
from the Academy will affect their verdict.
Smith's resignation comes on the heels of
the revelation by Oscars producer Will Packer
that the Los Angeles Police Department had sent
officers to the scene ready to arrest Smith,
but were told not to by Rock, who was reportedly
in high spirits after the incident. In fact,
he even joked that he took a punch from
"Muhammad Ali" in reference to Smith's
turn as the late boxing legend in 2001's
"Ali." After Rock declined to press charges,
Packer stopped Academy staff from ejecting
Smith out of the event, and the rest is history.
What effect the debacle will have on
Will Smith's acting career is uncertain,
though some say there's hope for a rebound
if he avoids becoming a tabloid headline
for the foreseeable future. Then again,
as this situation has proven already,
there are likely plenty more twists and
turns ahead that, for all anyone knows,
could adversely impact Smith's career. All
we can do is wait and see what happens next.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Oscars
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don’t miss a single one.